hello everyone garry kasparov often said
that he really liked Michael tall as a
person and that he really enjoyed his
games but he also said that the most of
the adult attacks would definitely be
refuted by today's modern grandmasters
but it's interesting in this game he
defeats his opponent exactly in the
style of Michael Tao first he sacrifices
some material to gain initiative then he
sacrifices some more material and then
well he makes his opponent think and he
gives him a lot of options to choose
from his opponent is exhausted and well
being in time trouble see blunders and
as far away into the game so pretty much
exactly like Michael Tao and this game
was played in 1980 in the seventh
European Championship and Garry Kasparov
was 18 years old at the time this game
was played so gallery is white and the
yosef three votes black we have d4
Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to c3 c5 the
groennfell defense seek a person d5
Knight chapters on d5 and now e4 we have
Knight captures on c3 be captures on c3
and Bishop to g7 Knight to f3 b6 and
conspire plays Bishop to b5 check
we have c6 Bishop back to c4 and out
castles also castles and Bishop to a6
and okay Kasparov captures the bishop
different casters on a6 90% a six and
now not a queen to a for attacking this
knight on a six we have the Queen to CH
defending the knight and our Kasparov
plays Bishop to g5 developing developing
the base of Bishop - and I Square and
also attacking the e7 so we have Queen
to b7
now defending this e seven pawn and this
is a good move because power can't
really win this pawn on e7 if you would
play Bishop captures only seven Queen
Castor's 97 Queen captures on a6 then
simply Queen captures on e4 and this is
OK for black so after just a second
after Queen to b7 Kasparov decided to go
rook rook at the e1 so now he is
defending this e4 pawn and he is
definitely threatening to capture on e7
soul e6 is played we have rook a to be 1
and
now you also get an idea that he would
like to play c5 and he does this is the
world opening up the Queen's diagonal
and also he he wants to break up white
strong center here attacking this d4
pawn and this is the D pawn never moved
then this Bishop will capture the c3
pawn but this was actually Kasparov's
idea and Hispano plays d5 here he offers
this form just to create this this past
d5 form so we have Bishop captures on c3
rook to d1 we have eek after 75 he
captures on d5 and okay
Kasparov is down upon but he does have
this nice d5 platform we have Bishop to
g7 and the Kasparov pushes forward d6
and now we have f6 attacking this Bishop
and g5 and in this position well
Kasparov says about this position that
this this next move really cut the board
in half and it really makes your
opponent think and because for our place
is b7 first first he gave up this c3
pawn to create a passed pawn and now
he's given up a piece to put this
spaceborne further because you know best
pawns must be pushed so you're this
accepts this he plays s captures an g5
and well okay because power does have a
passed pawn but it's not that easy to
convert this into some kind of an
advantage but Cafaro gets an idea he
plays Queen to c4 checks we have King
2hh and now Knight captures on g5 and
okay cuz power does have some threats
here with this nice to f7 check ideas
well definitely winning winning the
exchange here so you're the plays Bishop
to f6 this is definitely the best move
and because power plays nice to e6 and
this is the IDF I spoke at the whole
point of this piece sacrifice of the
bishop here was that this rook on a face
cannot be defended now for example if if
black will try to defend this rook with
something like rook to eat route route
the g8
then Kasparov found this beautiful move
rook to d6 and well let's say after
night to c7 crisper
has this very nice move of d8 Queen so
rook captures on d8 and now well rook
after sandy ace and whatever black plays
here white will be better for example if
if if nice capture is nice
then simply rook captures on g8 would
check and then Queen captures the nice
and e6 and this is well better for Less
better for white she will be up and D
exchange the thing goes if rook captures
rook and well one are the thing is if
black would try to win material here
with Bishop captures 98 and then simply
Queen to c3 check will be checkmate in
two moves
so after this nice to e6 you also saw
that this rook cannot be defended and he
plays nice sc7 so Kasparov plays Knight
captures a knife eight rook captures on
a face and now again that nice rook move
casparo found also works here so he
plays a rope to d6 and the thread is
pretty obvious rook captures on f6 and
then promoting to a queen so Bishop to
f7 Bishop d7 stopping this and now
another beautiful move likes part of a
v8 Queen so the Queen obviously has to
be captured
Bishop captures and v8 and now Queen to
c3 check we have pink g8 and now rock
the d7 and this rook to d7 is has a
couple of purposes which we'll see later
we have the bishop the bishop to f6 of
course defending because the threat was
Queen to g7 checkmate and now power
again plays a beautiful sequence of
moves Queen to c4 check we have King th8
and now Queen to f4 now with a double
attack on this night here we have Queen
to a6 and one black play this Queen to
a6 move he was going for something like
for example Queen captures on c7 and
then simply Queen casters on a2 and this
would be indeed playable for black after
rook captures on 87th and simply King to
g8 and well Lex can play this no problem
with this three passed point this is
okay for black but this is why I say
that he wants part 1 this game exactly
in the style of Macau after his power
plays Queen to f4 his opponent display
26
but he completely missed Kaspar was a
real threat which is Queen to h6 and the
pyro plate is going to h6 move and his
opponents resigned because there is no
defense against Queen captures on h7
that is checkmate so yeah a beautiful
game by by the 18 year old Gary Kasparov
and we're only a couple of hours away
from from around one of the same polish
championships we get Garrett as part
we'll be playing against Sergey Karjakin
with white pieces so full quite again to
start to start off the tournament so
that's it I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon